les restaurants du coeur ont ouvert il y
a toujours des français qui ont faim et
qui n'ont pas assez pour se nourrir
coluche n'est plus là pour pousser des
coups de gueule mais l'organisation des
restaurants du coeur a mis en place la
possibilité dans 150 villes de france de
livrer plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'europe à paris dans l'un des
restaurants du coeur reportage pascal
deschamps frédéric baskets
aux pieds d'un hôtel de luxe loin du
centre de la capitale un petit chapiteau
bleu prêté par un cirque c'est là que
s'est installé l'un des quatre
restaurants du coeur parisien ce matin
comme prévu plusieurs centaines de repas
attendait dans les cartons au menu
sardines à la tomate steak pommes de
terre fromage et fruit 1200 calories au
total un repas simple mais équilibré
dont tous ceux qui s'étaient déplacés ce
matin était pourtant privé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
quand les restaurants du coeur sont
fermés comment vous vous nourrissez brun
se débrouille cela fait un mois et demi
deux mois je suis à l'armée du salut ais
je me trouve en fin de droits totalement
et bombay le square on nous nourrit
on a un repas le soir et le midi mon il
faut que l'on se débrouille totalement
chômeurs en fin de droits anciens et
nouveaux pauvres les bénéficiaires des
restaurants du coeur n'ont pas changé
avec la même fin la même honte aussi au
creux du ventre une mère de famille a
refusé d'être filmé elle avait
simplement dit à ses enfants qu'elle
allait faire quelques courses en tout
150 repas ont été distribués aujourd'hui
l'an dernier le centre avait fini par en
donner 1000 par jour
premier jour l'ouverture évidemment
enfin pas mal débuté mi longueur
n'aurait eu un peu plus de propagande
peut être ni fils monde enfin disons que
leur vie si c'est pas mal
deux cent mille repas par jour jusqu'au
21 mars c'est l'objectif des restaurants
du coeur cette année mais même si le
prix de revient d'un déjeuner est tombé
de 5 francs à trois francs 85 il leur
faudra encore beaucoup de dons pour y
parvenir